hello everyone my name is Metta atomo
I'm a developer advocate and today I
want to talk about an app modernization
story with cloud run back in early 2016
a friend of mine and I we wanted to
build a news aggregator app in this app
we would go and fetch news articles from
various news sources and we will display
them in a mobile app in a clean timeline
my friend worked on the mobile front end
while I work on the back end in this
presentation I want to talk about the
modernization journey or the back end
the beckham was initially written with
asp.net 4.6 it was a Windows app and it
was deployed on an iOS host there were
three main services the reader would
fetch the RSS feeds the transformer will
would convert them into a common format
that we defined and the web api would
serve the feeds to the mobile front end
the initial prototype we worked on on a
couple of weekends and it worked it was
very easy to understand and it was very
easy to deploy because everything was
bundled together also the ISS was quite
inexpensive at the same time the app had
issues from the beginning first of all
there was too much coupling between
services all three services they were
all bundled together the developer
experience of the is host was not great
sometimes the machine where our
application was running on would go down
and we wouldn't know why or if it had to
look at the logs of the application
I had to FTP into the Machine and
download the walks we didn't have any
kind of redundancy any kind of
persistence or any kind of resilience so
if there were any issues with any of the
services it could potentially bring down
our whole application but this was the
initial prototype and it was a good
start and it served us well for about a
year but in 2017 we started looking into
moving our application to a better place
that's when we came across compute
engine compute engine
there are virtual machines on Google
Cloud where you can have as Linux or
Windows based virtual machines so we
took our app and we deployed to a
Windows server on compute engine
then we configured it the way we liked
and then we created what's called an
instance template out of our VM instance
template is kind of like a snapshot or
your VM and then you can use it to
create instance groups reject which are
identical VMs load-balanced behind the
cloud load balancer with this setup we
got redundancy we have 2 BM during our
application we got world balancing with
cloud load balancer via and we also got
possibility auto scaling because with
instance groups you can set metrics and
use those metrics to auto scale if you
need to it was a very easy to move we
didn't have to change our code you just
had to deploy to the Windows Server on
compute engine and the developer
experience with Google Cloud was much
better we have integrated logging with
stock driver we had VM snapshots for
backup and recovery and we had easy
access to our VMs with remote RDP at the
same time things were getting more
expensive instead of running on a single
machine shared by other applications we
were running on two dedicated VMs and we
had a little buzzer as well even though
it wasn't that expensive it was more
than we wanted for a hobby application
but this set up searle as well for a
couple years from 2017 to 2019 there
were a few interesting things happening
in the tech world especially in dotnet
world first of all there was this new
version of.net called dotnet core and
the most interesting thing about the
core is that it can run on multiple
platforms Linux Mac or Windows secondly
there was a lot of hype around
containers everyone was talking about
how to take a single monolith
application running on a VM and how to
break it down into smaller pieces and
run them in containers in a much more
efficient way
third we
our windows dependency our application
was a Windows application and that
limited REO our deployment options and
we wanted to get rid of that at some
point and last the cost our application
even though it wasn't that much it was
still something that we wanted to bring
down so all of these forces came into
play and in early 2019 we started
looking to have two containerize our
application
now before continuation we have to first
convert up our application from net to
the rykor so we rewrote our application
they set up neck or 2.2 the latest
version at the time and this took a
weekend we were pleasantly surprised
because we were expecting at least
couple of weeks to do the conversion but
we have all the libraries that we needed
and everything that we we were using on
the net they were only available at that
core now once we will have our
application of mcore we freed ourselves
from Windows and we could run on Linux
that's when we got into containerization
we container is our application with
docker using some base images provided
by Microsoft and then we could deploy to
multiple places in Google Cloud there
were two good options first google
kubernetes engine and second app engine
we chose App Engine because all we
needed was a web front-end and
everything was bundled together so App
Engine sold as well google kubernetes
engine could have been better because it
provided infrastructure for more complex
architectures but App Engine was enough
for us so that's that's why we went with
App Engine with this set up the windows
license fees were out so our application
was running on Linux and it was cheaper
to run we got hassle-free auto scaling
because in App Engine you get auto
scaling without having to do anything
special and we got the nice features of
App Engine such as revision management
and traffic splitting but we were still
running on virtual machines and App
Engine does a good job of hiding the
fact that you are running on virtual
machines but we
the scenes when happened reflects you
are running on virtual machines and you
need to pay those virtual machines per
second
this meant that our application when it
was not used especially during the
evenings we were still paying for those
VMs at all times
also the deployment of App Engine they
were kind of slow it was it could take
anywhere from five to ten minutes even
though it wasn't a big problem it slowed
us down during our development cycle
around mid 2019 something new came along
called cloud run and the whole premise
or cloud run is to bring service
features to containers this was break
saving for us because our application
was already containerized and we were
already looking into running it in a
server this way especially when it comes
to billing so in mid-2000 also like to
mention mentioned that cloud run it has
a couple of use cases first one is
public endpoints cloud run is very good
for that and also the second use case is
private endpoints where you need to do
some kind of background tasks cloud run
is good fit for that as well and both of
these use cases were the use cases or
application we had a web front-end that
was public and we had internal services
that could be private endpoints on
called run and also the best part of
cloud run was its billing time in club
run even though your container might be
running for a while you only pay for the
time that the requests are being handled
this meant that our application when it
wasn't being used in the evenings it
could scale down to zero and will pay
nothing
so with these in mind we tried to deploy
our application to kelabra in mid-2000
19 to do that first we upgraded our
application to the latest version of SPF
core 3.0 and then deploy into cloud
realm was a single command G cloud app
run deployed and it was there we then
had to change anything now with this we
got service billing and this really
brought that
our billing considerably because we
weren't paying for anything when our
application wasn't being used we also
got awesome developer experience with
cloud run we had fast deploys so we
could deploy within seconds instead of
minutes and we got integrated logging
with stack driver and we kept all the
awesome features of cloud run with
traffic management and revision
management and so on at the same time we
were still running as a single
monolithic application and we had
monolith issues those one of the issues
were first scaling we could only scale
all-or-nothing if we have to scale the
web front-end because there were more
users we had to scale the reader and the
converter as well and this wasn't ideal
for us because we had to scale
individual services as we need it but we
couldn't do that in a monolithic
application second we had an issue with
cold starts so when our application
wasn't being used
it was scaled down to zero and this was
great for billing but at the same time
when the first user came along our
application would wake up it didn't have
any kind of persistence so it had to go
and fetch their feeds then it had to
transform them and it had to serve to
the user so this meant that the the
first user it could wait it could wait
for a while for the data to show up and
this was becoming a big issue third all
of the state was in memory we didn't
have any kind of backup state and we
wanted to have something more persistent
and lastly we didn't have a way to
update individual services most of the
times we didn't have to update our
reader or our web api but we had to
change rules about how to how to
transform their SS feeds even though we
have we only had to change this small
piece or our location we had to update
our whole application because it was a
monolith so with these issues in mind we
in stage four we started looking into
how to break down more width into
smaller micro services this was early
2020 and this is what we came up with
first we had
new service called reader this is a
private club run service it's private
meaning it doesn't have a public
endpoint and all it does is it goes and
fetches RSS feeds and brings them back
now this reader is being caught by cloud
scheduler which is a scheduling service
on Google Cloud and scheduler with call
reader once an hour every hour and
neither would go and fetch the feeds and
it would save the feeds into cloud
storage which is a cloud-based object
storage service now once once the feeds
are certain saved into cloud storage
cloud storage can generate notifications
to a pop subtopic and these
notifications they can be served to
another class service called converter
this converter
it's another habit cloud service and it
will look at the list of rules that we
defined and it would transform this RSS
feeds from different format into a
common format that we defined once
they're put into the common format
they're saved into cloud fire store this
is a fully managed no sequel database
and it's perfect for JSON like data and
then we had another public cloud service
called web this was the public front-end
or application the users the end-users
the mobile app would go and ask for the
feeds from the web service and the web
would just look at five store and fetch
the latest data from there as you can
see we broke our monolith into three
separate microservices two of them are
private services because they don't need
to be public one of them is public they
are totally independent from each other
so the reader doesn't have to know about
the converter and the web doesn't need
to care about the converter or the
reader they are all event-driven so they
don't need to call each other in a
synchronous way and they can be
individually scaled so if you have more
users we can only a scale web front-end
we don't have to scale the widow or the
converter and there they can be
individually updated as well usually the
neat update Reader and web
because the way we read and the way we
serve is always the same but we have to
update firmware to quite often because
there rules around RSS feed feed they
change quite a lot and this setup allows
us to do that so with this setup even
though it's a little bit more
complicated we solve all the issues that
we had with the previous application now
the lessons learned in this
transformation journey
first of all transformation does not
have to be all or nothing as you can see
from our journey it was a step-by-step
transformation where each step is
something new to our application and
remove some legacy and open the way for
new technologies secondly sometimes you
need to use non optimal solutions to get
ready for optimal solutions for example
in our case when you look at it app
engine's Flex was probably not the most
optimal solution because we were still
running on VMs cloud run was the optimal
solution because we needed a
event-driven microservices kind of
environment and that's what cloud run
allowed us to do but to get from our VM
to cloud run we have to use App Engine
in the middle and by doing that we went
from a dotnet
Windows app to Adamic or app running on
App Engine it wasn't ideal but it served
us well because in the next iteration we
could much easier move from App Engine
flex to quadrant
third even simple things like lift and
shift to the cloud can have huge
benefits in our application by moving
from iOS to Google cloud we didn't have
to really change any of our code all we
had to change was our deployment and
where we deploy but by doing that we can
instance tablets instance groups and
load balancing and and with those we got
more resilience and redundancy so to get
benefits you don't always need to change
your code you can just change your
environment and still get those benefits
and at some point you should expect some
kind of rewrite especially if you want
to use the benefits of the
that you're running in for example in
our case when we deploy to Club run
initially we deployed as a single
monolith we got some benefits but it
wasn't all the benefits of club run to
truly use the benefits of cloud run we
had to actually decompose our
application into micro services and we
had to make them event-driven and for
that we had to restructure our code and
had to break it down so it was a lot of
work that was needed you know in order
to use cloud run in a way that made
sense for us and we all talked about
mobile applications and how they're bad
and how we should break them break them
down into smaller pieces and it's
usually true but at the same time this
is a hard process it involves
refactoring and restructuring your code
and then it involves figuring out how
this new services will communicate with
each other whether it's gonna be
event-driven or whether it's gonna be
synchronous and what kind of storage
they're going to use so there's all
these questions that you need to answer
monolithic decomposition it's something
that you should take it very seriously
and you should have a really good reason
to do it
if you want to do it so that's all I
have for today hopefully this was useful
and if you want to read more about this
application I wrote a blog post serious
where I explain in more detail what this
application is about and give you more
details about it and the code is as well
on github so if you want to take a look
at the backend code it's out there and
thanks very much for listening thank you